[Musique]
lockhart tous oui pas al omari la forêt
est absente temps c'est moi ma rue du
bois ta part de qui jacques dutronc l
eau robespierre oui telle qu'on fait
dans ton une question à trancher alors
jeanne oui ici tarzan est alors par son
retard pour dîner pourquoi parce que
tarzan raté liane 8h47 à l'os et
beaumarchais
non c'est vilain chirac et l'aunis
l'intérieur wii sort dehors si t'es un
homme l amiral dennis k -o le bateau
c'est acura c ou à sous marins c'est
dingue lui raser alors on ghoul allé au
feeling oui on puisse trouver hamlet
hamlet aux champignons à la spa
oui qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand un chien
n'a pas assez à manger on augmente sa
ration je remercie je vais le dire à mon
maître et welsh foucault 1 est ici
blaise pascal et alors fait un petit
poker ce soir d'accord parce qu'un
tiendra avec des cartes à l'horloge
parlante d'ougrée l'heure exacte au
quatrime taux qui sera exactement 18
heures 74 minutes
ah bon je reviendrai plus tard à lomé
sur why et je paye oui où en sont vos
parties ça traîne elle au prince charles
et à la d'un hall est absent pour
combien de temps mille et une nuits où
puissent se joindre à shéhérazade
alors maréchal foch vous avez des
preuves aloha moiselle d'arc wiki qui
causent deviner saint-georges vous
brûlez déjà à monsieur charlemagne
oui ne quittez pas vous parle de
roncevaux j'écoute
[Musique]
allo pourrais-je parler à dieu ni est
absent à l'an passé - marc alaux d'apice
oui c'est chloé et ça tient alors louis
xiv oui c'est louis 15e gagner à l'eau y
circulent serrer le frein à main le
moment oui c'est jésus non mais si elle
est la reine sort i 4 je vous écoute
mentir rappelez moi qui a dit labourage
et pâturage sont les deux mamelles de la
france c'est sully les jeux même pas où
je manque qui le mit règle oui c'est jo
ni ses bienfaits fallait laver l'eau
tiède
alors que l'hiver oui ici lilliput mon
soir madame alors accueilli française
oui j'ai parlé au secrétaire perpétuel
et moi c'est moi c'est moi c'est moi
c'est moi
[Musique]